hi there steve kaufman here today i want
to talk about
languages and politicians
and
the reason is that we recently had the
the selection or the election of the
leader of the conservative party of
canada
his name is andrew scheer
and
so i was kind of curious to know how
well he spoke french because
a little less than a quarter of the
population of canada speaks french as
their first language and i believe that
anyone who's going to be prime minister
of canada
which the leader of the conservative
party one day hopefully or at least you
know he aspires to become
i think he should speak french and speak
it well so i looked up on youtube
andrew scheer who is i think he um
looking at his uh cv he was born in
ottawa he went to the university of
ottawa ottawa is a city that's about 30
french speaking
uh but then he's been living in western
canada
where there's not so many french
speakers
so i look at them up looked him up on
youtube and his french is really
i mean it's i would say
how would i call it it's not fluent
uh it's and what i you know one i think
real good test of fluent is
does the speaker make you feel
comfortable
uh when andrew scheer speaks french i
don't feel comfortable i think a
francophone who spoke english at all
well would say well thanks for trying
andrew but now let's speak english so we
can really communicate
he can say things in a speech but i saw
his performance at this candidate's
debate and when asked a specific
question in french he had trouble
kind of explaining his thoughts his
pronunciation isn't very good he's not
what i consider to be fluent
i think he should be fluent
and so then i thought to myself here i
am
now i'm going out to bratislava
i've spent you know
probably less than a week on slovak
i think that i'll be able to defend
myself as well in slovak as he does in
french um
i have the advantage that i've studied
um czech for a year but then that's a
year like an hour and a half a day using
link never immersed in czech
and yet if i look at my statistics on
link i have read one and a half million
words of check just on link not counting
books and newspapers that i have read
not on the computer
i have
according to the way we counted link i
have 65 000 known words in check
i have saved 55 000 words and phrases in
other words created links those are
words that i deliberately or phrases
highlighted and saved to my database
i have spoken with people tutors that
link 50 hours which isn't very much
so
all of that i've done for my check which
now can be transferred to some extent
because i'm now doing a lot of listening
in slovak i've downloaded an audiobook
with the ebook i'm working through the
ebook at link and so forth and so on
and in four or five days in in
bratislava i'm fairly confident that
i'll be able to defend myself in slovak
better than andrew scheer does in french
and i think that uh you know it's
interesting politicians it's it's in
different countries people look at it
differently uh i know that in ukraine
for example the president of ukraine is
a native speaker of russian
but for political reasons
i've never heard him speak russian in a
public forum which i find strange on the
other hand in ukraine there are
ministers of the ukrainian government
who never speak ukrainian they always
speak russian
i don't understand i don't know in
belgium if the prime minister there
speaks both flemish and french i would
think he should
i don't know what the situation is in
switzerland but
certainly in in canada although many
anglophones don't agree i think
that anyone who aspires to be prime
minister should be
comfortable in french and in english
so i would hope that mr sheer will spend
the time to to listen and read it's not
good enough to get a tutor who teaches
him about the subjunctive and other
niceties of the language he actually has
to expose himself to a lot of the
language through listening and reading
and so i would welcome him to link i'd
be happy to give him advice on how to
you know get the most out of link
and i hope that in the next two years
the canadian election
is going to be in 2019
that he would be able to get his french
level up by that time
uh
just a quick note uh
to end up here
um yeah by the way i am going to
bratislava
and i'm going to spend five days there
at this polyglot gathering then i'm
going to ukraine where for six days i'm
going to do three hours of russian in
the morning and three hours of ukrainian
in the afternoon to try and improve the
level of those languages at a school
which is not something i normally do
we'll see you know how that works out
and i'll probably make some videos while
i'm there now on the conservative party
of canada just for those people who
aren't familiar with canadian politics
uh there's a lot of debate in the u.s
liberals and conservatives and what does
a conservative mean and we're proud
conservatives and all this stuff that
you hear
i would say a good portion probably the
majority of people who vote conservative
in canada
would be moderate democrats in the
united states
certainly
i think
most of them are not interested in
making issues of sort of social
conservatism
like uh
same-sex marriage or pro-life versus
pro-choice they don't want to make these
um
issues they don't want those to be front
and center they aren't part of the party
platform people can hold the views that
they want but
the law is the law and
the conservative party's not going to
challenge those laws
similarly
i don't think there's anyone in the
conservative party who would be opposed
to uh
single-payer universal health care uh
many canadians feel that our system
should be more flexible
we should have more private delivery
uh other more flexibility such as they
have in europe i don't think our medical
system is by any means the best of the
universal uh you know comprehensive
coverage systems in the world but the
principle
of everyone being covered i don't think
there's a conservative who would oppose
that in canada
i um
you know i i would vote conservative
because i think that the the present
liberal government is spending money
that they don't have uh i think that
you know i favor uh social spending i
favor spending money on education on
health even on on you know child care
but then tax people for it let people
know what it's costing them don't you
know put this on future generations via
these large deficits that they're
running up
uh and i don't believe that uh
you know certainly the evidence from
northern europe is that you can have a
somewhat higher level of taxation it
doesn't kill entrepreneurship so i don't
buy that argument either a big reason
why i support the conservatives is that
i believe that in canada there is such a
thing as as a canadian
identity a canadian culture a sense of
belonging that we have as canadians and
the liberal government is far too prone
to promoting this idea that that
canadian identity is diversity that
there is no mainstream culture the more
diverse we are the better and i don't
believe that i think diversity is
essentially irrelevant uh you can be in
a community where they're all
uh you know whatever of one origin
perhaps in quebec they're all
francophone uh people with french names
or in nova scotia there's no immigrants
or whatever it doesn't matter and within
a generation or two all these immigrants
eventually assimilate to the canadian
mainstream and that you know we should
be encouraging people
to uh to join the broader community and
and making them feel welcome and saying
that it doesn't matter what your name is
what you look like you're equally
representative of what it is to be a
canadian but we don't encourage you you
may do whatever you want on your own but
we as a government shouldn't be
encouraging people to identify with
their
countries of origin they'll do that on
their own
very happily if they feel like it so and
because uh the new leader andrew shearer
is has come out strongly in favor this
sense of canadian identity let people
join the mainstream as opposed to what
justin trudeau and his liberals are
doing then i support the conservatives
let's not run these horrendous deficits
let's not promote the idea that there is
no canadian identity
uh
and so to that extent i support the
conservatives but i do not buy into any
of this sort of conservatism that seems
to be
uh you know front and center with the
republican party of the united states i
don't even understand it i don't know
where those people are coming from
and i think to that extent i'm quite
representative of people who of a
majority of people who would vote for
the conservatives here in canada
anyway there you have it a little bit
about politicians and language i hope
andrew scheer improves his french and we
would love to help him out here at link
so if anybody knows andrew scheer tell
him that i'm happy to help him out i
would like him to be fluent in french so
that he can win the next election
thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you